ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้องเรียมสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนค่ะครู
เรียมคะวันนี้นะคะนะวันนี้วันนี้วันนี้
ครูเรียมกับครูเอ๋มาพูดด้วยกันระดับไหนคะ
ระดับเริ่มต้นค่ะเร็วต้นไหนบีกินเนอร์วัน
ใช้ค่ะ
ตื่นเต้นไม่คุณเป็นตึก
1 เต้นมากๆก็เรียงตื่นเต้นนะหัวใจน่ะ
จุ๊บๆๆๆใช่ค่ะขอใจเป้นจุ๊บๆๆๆ
แรงมากไม่เป็นไรใจเย็นๆใจเย็นๆนะคะเดี๋ยว
โคเรียมเดี๋ยวสิ่งที่เค้าแช่ Skin นิดนึง
นะคะได้ค่ะวันนี้ครูเรียมวันนี้เนี่ยวัน
วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันอาทิตย์ค่ะวันอาทิตย์
นะคะอ่ะโอเค
ไม่เป็นไรอะมีก็ได้ไม่เคยเห็นมากเลยนะ
วันอาทิตย์นะคะวันนี้วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวัน
ที่
24 วันที่
24 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนตุลาคมเดือน
ตุลาคมนะคะปีคศต.ค.เท่าไหร่คะปีคศ
2000  21
ปีคอพ.ศตตัวเท่าไหร่คะ AE ผช
2564 ใครค่ะสอบวันนี้วันวันนี้นะคะวัน
อาทิตย์
วันที่ 24 เดือนอะไรนะคะครูเรียมเดือน
ตุลาคมค่ะปีค.ศต.ยนะคะมีข้อ
2021 ปีพตเท่าไหร่คะปีพศ
2564 ค่ะ
เย้
[เพลง]
ก็ครูเรียมกับครูเอ๋เอ๋นะคะเล็กคอร์ดเทป
วันอาทิตย์นะคะวันอาทิตย์วันนี้วันนี้ครู
เรียมจะมีรูปใช่ไหมคะรูปอะไรให้นักเรียน
ดูคะ
วันนี้ครูเรียมมีรูปบ้านให้นักเรียนดูค่ะ
บ้านเป็นยังไงคะครูเอ๋อยากเห็นบ้านนัก
เรียนก็ไม่เข้าใจบ้าน
บ้านเป็นแบบนี้ค่ะ
ป้านนะคะบ้านที่รูปของครูเรียมมีอะไรบ้าง
คะ
พรุ่งนี้มีอะไรครูเรียมชี้ให้ดูหน่อยมี
บ้านมีบ้านราคาบ้านหมอที่คุณเอ็มชิข้างบน
เนี่ยเรียกว่าอะไรคะ
ตรงนี้ใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะ
หลังคาหลังเกาะหลังคาบ้านนะคะมีประตูไหม
คะ
มีค่ะตรงไหนคะตรงนี้คือประตูหอประตูบ้าน
ประตูบ้านมีกี่บานคะ
มี 2 บานค่ะมีสองบาน
122 โอเคค่ะแล้วมีนะต่างไหมคะมีค่ะหน้า
กากยกอะไรคะอยู่ตรงนี้ค่ะหรอมีหน้าต่าง
กี่บานคะมีหน้าต่าง
4 บานค่ะสิบสี่บานเหรอคะใช่ไหม
ที่ไหนวะตรงนี้ตรงนี้ขอก็ตรงนี้เรียก
หน้าต่างไหมคะรู้มีหน้าต่างไว้หน้าต่างก็
ได้นะหน้าต่างใหญ่วาฬใหญ่
หน้าตันใหญ่นะคะมีหน้าต่างเละ
[เพลง]
อีก 2 คันค่ะของคันคัดคันไหนบ้างคะ
อันที่ 1 คันที่ 2 มีรถสีดำ 2 คันค่ะรถสี
ดำ 2 คันมีรถสีขาว
1 คันค้านทั้งหมดกี่คันคะทั้งหมด 3 คัน
ค่ะ 3,000 แล้วครูเอ๋เห็นมีสีเขียวมีสี
เสียวๆสีเขียวเขียวๆสีเขียวตรงนี้ใช่ไหม
คะใช่ค่ะอะไรคะ
ก็เป็นสนามหญ้าสนามหญ้านะคะเรียกว่าสนาม
หญ้าเนาะนะๆเรียกว่าสนามหญ้างั้นรูปนี้ก็
จะมีบ้าน
1 หลังๆ
อยู่ข้างบนหลังคาบ้าน
ค่ะหลังคาบ้านค่ะมีหน้าต่าง
บานเล็ก 3 บานใช้ค่ะมีหน้าต่างใหญ่
1 บานใช่ค่ะมีมีอะไรอีกนี่ประตูประตู
ประตูประตู 2 บาทนะคะมีรสทั้งหมด 3 คัน
ใช้คะรสสีขาวกี่คันนะรถสีขาว 1 คันค่ะรถ
สีดำกี่คันคะรสสีดำ
2 คันค่ะแล้วก็มีอะไรคะสีเขียวสีเขียวมี
สนามหญ้าสีเขียวมีสนามหญ้าสีเขียวและคู่ a
เห็นยังมีอีกหนึ่งอย่าง
อะไรคะใกล้ๆรถสีดำใกล้ๆประตู
ตรงนี้ใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะ
ตรงนี้เป็นกระถางต้นไม้
กระถางอาหารกระถานสำหรับปลูกต้นไม้ปลูก
ต้นไม้ค่ะเอาใกล้ๆใกล้ๆๆ
นักเรียนเห็นนะอ๋อมีกระถางต้นไม้
S สวยนะคะแล้ว
ครูเอ๋เห็นข้างหน้าข้างหน้าประตูมีอะไรคะ
ทั้งหน้าประตูมีคนมีคนนะคะคนอีกกี่คนคะคน
หนึ่งคนค่ะผู้หญิงคู๋ผู้หญิงอาโคเรียมผู้
หญิงคนนี้ผู้ชายคนเป็นผู้หญิงหรือผู้ชาย
คะคนเป็นผู้ชายค่ะเป็นคนผู้ชายนะคะเอ๊ะ
ครูเห็นที่ที่หน้าต่างบานใหญ่เมื่อกี้
เห็นนักเรียนเห็นไหมมีอะไรคะอันนั้นโต๊ะ
ไหมคะมีโต๊ะทำงานมีโต๊ะนะคะมีโต๊ะ
แล้วมีอะไรอีกครั้งเก้าอี้
มีเก้าอี้ด้วยค่ะอ่ามีเก้าอี้กี่ตัวคะ
มีกี่ตัวนะใกล้ๆใช่ไหมครูเอ๋ช่วยดู
กูเอนดู
รู้เห็นไหมคะ R ใกล้ๆกูเอ๋กำลังดูอยู่กู
เห็นเก้าอี้
123  R  R ถ้ามีคอมพิวเตอร์เออให้ค่ะมี
คอมพิวเตอร์มีเก้าอี้เก้าอี้ 2  3 นะยัง
ไงก็รู้สึกสาม
สาวนะหนึ่งใช่ข้างหลังคอมพิวเตอร์หนึ่ง
ตัว
จะได้คะอันนี้คอมพิวเตอร์แล้วข้างหน้า
คอมพิวเตอร์หนึ่งตัว
แล้วก็ทางสายวันสายไหมอีก 1 ตัวเก้าอี้ 3
ตัวใช่ไหมคะโอ้โหเก้าอี้ 3 ตัว
ครูเอ๋แต่ดีผ้าดีมากค่ะตาที่ว่าปากยาว
ต้องมองใกล้ๆ
ใกล้ๆไม่เห็นฮ่าๆๆ
a  f  Korea มีรูปบ้านเป็นบ้านของใคร
เป็นบ้านของเรียม
อันนี้เป็นอ่ะเรียกว่าแปลนบ้านใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่ค่ะเตรียมกำลังจะสร้างบ้านแม่อ๋อเรียม
คิดใช่มั้ยอ้ะเอางั้นคิดทำบ้านใช่มั้ยอ้ะ
ไรค่ะคำบ้านสร้างบ้านเหมือนกันค่ะอ๋ออ๋อ
ถ้าอย่างนั้นเรียมต้องมีที่ดินใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่ค่ะมีที่ดินมีเรื่องที่เปิดให้ดูได้
ค่ะ
วิธีที่เราเห็นไม่ถึงนี้อ่าอ่ะ
ก็
ได้ไหมเขามีต้นไม้ด้วยนี่เมื่อกี้ไม่มี
ต้นไม้เออใจค่ะ
แป๊บนึงนะได้ค่ะนักเรียนไม่เห็นไหมคะเป็น
บ้านแล้วก็มีรถ
3 คัน
โทษรูปนี้มีคน
2 คนนะคะค่ะมีคน 2 คน
แล้วก็ใกล้ๆบ้านมี
มีต้นไม้คุยมีรูปต้นไม้ไม่ไม่เป็นไรคุยมี
กระดาษ
มีต้นไม้
ต้นไม้นักเรียนต้นไม้เออต้นไม้มี 1  2  3
4 มีเริ่มต้นไม้สี่ต้นนะคะพี่เอ๋เห็นนะ
คะเดี๋ยวแป๊บนึงนะคะ
ผู้เรียนกำลังจะแชร์สกรีนที่ดินให้นัก
เรียนดูราคาโอเค
มาแล้วอันนี้ที่ดิน
ใช้ค่ะตรงนี้คือที่ดินตรงไหนนะคุณเรียม
ชี้ได้ไหม
ชีสๆให้ครูเอ๋ให้นักเรียนดู
ตอนนี้ไหมคะอ๋อกูเองมองเห็นไหมคะอ๋อกู
เห็นเป็น Square อ๋อ
เดี๋ยวลองแบบนี้
เป็นโรงรู้อ้าโอเคขอบคุณค่ะนั้นเป็นที่
ดินที่ดินค่ะคูเรียมสีดำสีดำๆคืออะไร
มีสีดำๆตรงนี้ใช่ไหมคะที่ที่สีดำเลยค่ะ
ชีวิตที่สีดำ
2 เลือกใช่ค่ะสีดำอะไรคะคือถ้าตะแลนน้อ
[เพลง]
หมู่บ้านใหญ่หรือบ้านเล็กบ้านหลังเล็ก
หลังเล็กกี่ชั้นคะ
มี
1 ชั้นค่ะ
1 ชั้นนะคะได้เห็นไหมคะ R ถ้าแบบนี้ก็จะ
เป็น 1  2 ใช่มั้ยฮะ 2 ชั้นอ่ะ 1  2  2
ชั้นแต่ครูเรียมทำบ้าน
1 ชั้นค่ะ 1 ชั้นหน้าก็เป็นที่ดินของครู
เรียมใช้เครื่องมีที่ดินน่ะเสร็จแล้ว
ต้องมีแปลนบ้าน
มีค่าการบ้านไหมคะ
นี้ค่ะแลนด์บ้านได้ไหมคะขอแปลนบ้านมาแบบ
นี้ค่ะ
เห็นแบบนี้อ่ะคู่ดิอ่าเดี๋ยวเราจะตอบก่อน
จะเป็นแบบนี้
เป็นแฟนบ้านของครูเรียมนะคะ
แฟนบ้านที่ที่รูปนี้มีอะไรบ้างคะที่เป็น
แฟนบ้านครูเรียม
มีต้นไม้มีต้นไม้
แล้วก็บ้าน
เหมือนกับคาบที่ 1 ไหมเหมือนกันมั้ย
เหมือนค่ะอ๋อแต่อันนี้เป็นข้างหลังหรอคะ
เลยค่ะอันนี้นี่เป็นครั้งหน้าค่ะออกข้าง
หน้า
ขอเวลามีแฟนบ้านจะมีมีมีกระดาษชนะที่
Korea มีกระดาษ 8 บ้านมีกี่แผ่นคะแต่คู๋
มีแผ่นโว้เยอะมากโอ้โหอ่ะ
น้ำหอมเย้ยใครเป็นคนว่าให้แฟนบ้าน
สถาปนิกค่ะคนนี้ไหม
ใช่ค่ะกับสถาปนิก
เห็นได้
สถาปนิดใช่ไหมคะ
สถาปนิกวาด 8 บ้านโอเค a อยากรู้
แพงไหม
โอเคไหม
บ้านหลังเล็กไม่แครงสถาปนิกสถาปนิกอ่ะคิด
เงินแพงไว้
แพง
อ่ะบ้านเท่าไหร่ไม่เป็นไร
สถาปนิกสถาปนิก
วัดแสวงเท้าวาดแปลนบ้านแพะแพงไหมคะอ่ะแต่
แพงค่ะ
แผนท้อแต่ก็โอเคนี่บอกได้ไหมเข้าไร
ราคาที่ฝ่ายสถาปนิด
สถาปนิก
10000  5,000 ดอลลาร์
บาท
ดอลลาร์
ดอลลาร์แพงมากมาหา
15,000 บาท
ก็แพงเนาะโอเคโอเคโอเค
ก็ถามป่ะนี่ที่ไหนคะที่กรุงเทพฯเหมือนที่
บ้านของน้องเรียนอยู่ที่บ้านค่ะ
ที่บ้านที่
นี่บริษัทละคามผู้เรียมไม่ได้อยู่ม
กรุงเทพครูเอกรุงเทพพน้องเรียมมหาสารคาม
แต่ครูเอ๋ก็ไม่รู้ราคาวัดสถาปนิกแพงไม่
แพงใช่มั้ยไม่รู้อะก็ 15,000 บาทเนาะนัก
เรียนชายแลงก์ไหม
แข่งไหมคะ
นะคู่เรียมอยากรู้ไหมอเมริกาสถาปนิกเนี่ย
เนาะ
สถาปนิกวาดแปลนบ้าน 1 ครั้ง
หนึ่งครั้งนะ
เข้าไหร่อ่ะ
ราคาเท่าไหร่เขาไหร่คะ
ครูเอ๋เอ๋ไม่รู้ครูเรียมไม่รู้
นักเรียนต้องเขียน
ที่เห็นข้างล่าง
เนาะใช่ค่ะ
โคเรียมครูเอ๋รู้นะคะขอบคุณก่อนนะคะ
ขอบคุณค่ะสำหรับบ้านหลังเล็กบ้านหลัง
5,000 บาทแพงไหมแทงไหม
ไม่รู้สำหรับครูเอ๋กับครูเรียมคิด
แพงแต่โอเคแพงแต่โอเคโอเคโอเคนะคะแพงโอเค
นะคะอ่ะแล้วมีมีกี่ห้องครับครูเรียม
เดี๋ยวครูเรียมแพหน้าจอให้ดูนะคะๆค่ะได้
ค่ะ
อยู่ไหนน้าอยู่ไหนอยู่ไหน
เจอไหมอ่ะถ้า
เจอไม่เข้าแล้วข้า
เจอไหม
นักเรียนรอดูอ้าวมาแล้ว
แล้วค่ะมีห้องอะไรบ้างคะ
มีห้องครัวตรงไหนคะห้องครัว
ตรงนี้ค่ะอ๋อห้องกูตัว
ห้องครัวสำหรับทำอาหารเนาะใช้หาทำอาหาร
แล้วก็กิน
ครูเอชอบห้องครัว
เรารู้จักใหญ่นะ
ค่ะครัวมีห้องครัวแล้วมีห้องอะไรอีกคะมี
ห้องเก็บของอ่าห้องอันนี้ก็คือถ้ามีขวด
น้ำมีอะไรล่ะมี
มีเก้าอี้
อาอาอาที่ไม่ใช้ก็เก็บอะไรหาเก็บไว้ห้อง
นี้ค่ะห้องเก็บของราคา
ใช่ค่ะมีห้องคะตรงนี้ก็เป็นห้องนั่งเล่น
อ๋อนั่งนั่งเล่นที่ยังไงนั่งสบายสบายใช้
หันนั่งสบายๆนั่งดูทีวีก็ได้อ๋อ
อ่ะอ่ามีทีวีใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็ดูทีวีมี
หนังสือ
ชายค่ะแล้วก็อ่านหนังสือได้อ่านหนังสือ
มีโซฟาไหมอ่ะ
ในรูปไม่มีค่ะอ๋อไม่มีแต่ครูเรียมจะซื้อ
นะคะถ้าให้ค่ะเป็นห้องนั่งสบายๆนะฮะเรียก
มากห้องนั่งเล่นขอราคามีห้องอะไรอีกคะมี
ห้องน้ำตรงไหนคะ
วันนี้ค่ะห้องน้ำ
มี 2 หลัง 2 ห้อง
คู่เลียม YouTube คน
อยู่คนเดียวค่ะอยู่ 1 คนทำไมมีห้องน้ำ 2
ห้องมีห้องน้ำส่วนตัวขอ
เข้าห้องน้ำส่วนตัวห้องน้ำเวลาเรียมนอน
ใช่มั้ยเพราะตรงนี้ห้องนอนมั้ยติดห้องนอน
ตรงนี้ห้องนอนค่ะห้องนอน
เกาะห้องน้ำห้องที่ 1
ข้างในห้องนอน
ใช่ค่ะคะพี่
แล้วห้องน้ำที่ 2 ห้องน้ำที่ 2 อ่ะก็จับ
ห้องนั่งเล่นห้องนั่งเล่นนะคะ
ก็ถ้าคู๋ไปบ้านครูเรียมก็เข้าห้องน้ำที่ 2
ราผู้เหนกูเลี้ยงกูเลี้ยงตัวเองปวดฉี่คู๋
ดื่มน้ำเนี่ยกินน้ำมากๆปวดฉี่ห้องน้ำที่
ไหนคะอยู่ตรงนี้ค่ะโอเคคุยไปห้องน้ำก่อน
นะ
ชายก็จะเป็นห้องน้ำที่ 2 สำหรับ
คนไปที่บ้านใครเค้าก็ห้องน้ำที่หนึ่งใน
ห้องนอนนะคะใช้ค่ะแล้วมีห้องอะไรอีกค่ะ
ตรงนี้เป็นห้อง
บันทึกเสียง
อ๋อของทำ
ทำคลิปค่ะทำอะไรอ่ะณห้องบันทึกเสียงจะ
เป็น
ห้องบันทึกเสียง
เป็นยังไงคะ
เย้นี้ค่ะ
ห้องห้องทำงานของครูเรียมเนื่องช่ายรถตรง
นี้มีห้องทำงานอีกนะคะห้องทำงานอันนี้
ห้องทำงานอะไร
ห้องมีโต๊ะทำงาน
แล้วก็ของแป้ง
น้าาเพราะว่าครูเรียมทำงาน 1  2  3  34
อย่างใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะกลับไม่ได้
เหนื่อย
เพราะว่าต้องขับรถไปออฟฟิศ R ต้องสอนภาษา
ไทยต้องค่ะจะทำอะไรนะ Audio  Audio  Book
Audio  Book นะคะอ๋อก็จะมีห้องห้องทำงาน
2 ห้องนะคะห้องที่ 1 คือห้องแอบเป็นเล่น
คอร์ด Audio เนอะแล้วก็ข้องที่ 2
เป็นห้องทำงานทำงานนะคะ
[เพลง]
น่าอยู่ค่ะครูเอกช่องเอ็มยูมาอยู่กับครู
เดียวกับอาหารให้ดีค่ะดีกว่าเห็นชอบทำ
อาหารพระเอกไปทำอาหาร
ราคาขอ
ไม่มีขาดกับสะเทือนต้อง in  We  Are แล้ว
ต้องคุยกับวิศวกรด้วยไหมคะคุยค่ะต้องคุย
กับวิศวกรด้วยเพราะว่าเวลาทำบ้านน่ะก็จะ
มีสถาปนิกมีวิศวกรนะคะพี่ชาละคำมีมีหมวก
ด้วยนะ
มั่วว่าเดี๋ยวจะมีมีอะไรโหลดแล้วเนาะ Good
เต็ม
เจ็บก็ต้องพิมพ์หมวกใส่หมวดนะคะใส่หมวก
วิศวกรคืออะไรอยู่ตัวเองเห้ยถือ
แปลนบ้านแว่นบ้านเขื่อนเนี้ยเฮ้ยน่าจะไม่
ใช่อันนี้นะ
Stand
แบบนี้นะ
เพื่อน
ๆคิดว่าอันนี้อ่าคิดว่าอันนี้
วิศวกรต้องดูทั้งหมดนะคะอ๋อ
ว้าวหล่อนะวิศวกรวิศวกรหล่อหล่อๆพระเอก
ชอบ
ตัวเองชอบ
วิศวกรแต่วิศวกรไม่ชอบคู๋
กลับบ้านมีวิศวกรแล้วต้องมีมีมีช่างก่อ
สร้างด้วยไหมคะมีค่ะต้องมีช่างก่อสร้าง
ด้วย 1 คนโอเคไหมโอ้ยไม่พอมีให้หลายคนอาจ
จะมีสองสามสี่ห้านักเรียนมีช่างก่อสร้าง
ตอนนี้ก็จะพูดในรูปเนี่ยก็จะมีอันนี้
เรียกว่าอะไรนะเรียกว่าอะไรนะคะเกียง
เกียงๆเกียร์อาทิตย์ถืออยู่คือก็เรียงค่ะ
ส่วนตัวนี้ก็จะเป็นอิฐมอญ
แล้วก็ตรงนี้เป็นปูน
เพราะว่าเอาอ่าช่างก็จะเอาเกรียงน่ะปาด
ปูนแล้วก็หยิบอิฐมอญวางใช่ไหมว่างแล้วก็
ติดอีป๊อกๆป่าเทพปาดร้ายติดกันใช่ไหมคะ
อิฐหนึ่งก้อนสองก้อน 3 ปอนด์อ่ะติดกันติด
ติดกันใช้ปูนทำให้อิฐอิฐติดกันอ๋อที่เขา
เรียกว่าก่ออิฐใช่ไหมคะถ้าใช่อันนี้เรียก
ว่าก่อน it หน้า
แล้วเรียมก็ต้องมีอันนี้ด้วย
ช่างไม้อ่ะดีใจค่ะช่างไม้เขาก็จะมีไม้มี
ก็ไม่ทำอะไรอยู่คะเขามีเรื่อยแล้วก็
เลื่อยไม้ขอ
โควต้านี้เรา text หน่อยเนาะ
ด้วยไม้
เลื่อยไม้นะหาเรียมเรื่อยๆหมายได้ไหมคะ
ได้ค่ะมันเหนื่อยไหมได้เก่งมาก
เย้แอดไม่เก่ง
กูเอ๋เลื่อยไม้ไม่ได้เรื่อยๆนิ้วโอเค
เจ็บ
คู๋เมื่อก่อนเลื่อยไม้แต่นิ้ว
ก็ต้องมีช่างไม้เนาะมีอาหมายนะคะอ๊อดที่
นี่แบบให้
นักเรียนออกร้อนมีหรือองค์ช่างหมายเนี่ย
เขาก็จะมีมีเรื่อยนะคะมีอันนี้อะไรอ่ะขอน
ขอนใช่ไหมขอชื่อพี่คะใช่ๆ
เมดขอน
แล้วเขากำลังตอกตะปูอีกหรือเปล่าใช่ๆเขา
ออกกูมีแบบนี้มีตะปู
[เพลง]
กับนี้นะคะอ่า
กระปู
เราก็มีค้อน
มีแต่ว่า
มีค้อนนะคะ
โอเคโอเคไหมขอ
แล้วคอนก็อ่าอย่าตอกตอกตะปูอ้าใช่มั้ย
ต้องเรียนไม่ได้เป็น
ตัวเองเป็นไม้ก็ตอบกระปูนอ่ะลง
ลงไปที่ไม้
มีอะเดือนเห็นไหมช่างไม้ช่างนายมันจะ
เบอร์นิดนึงนะคะ
วันนี้ไข่
อ๋อ
ใช่กบใส่ไม้ไหมคะใช่ค่ะอ้าวเวลาไม้ไม้มัน
โอ๊ยเจ็บอ่ะอา
ไม้ไม่เรียบนะจะมีกบแล้วก็ใส่
ใส่
กบไสไม้ให้ใหม่เรียบได้หมายก็ RE เรียบ
เวลาเวลาจับไมค์เจ็บอาจใช่ไหมเจ็บมือทำ
ไม้ไม้ไม่เรียบน่ะเดี๋ยวคุยแค่สกรีนให้นะ
คะ
หมายไม่เรียกจะเป็นยังไงคะบ๊ายไม่เรียบ
เดี๋ยวกูเองกูเองรกอันนี้ก่อน
เวลามีไหมใช่ไหมคะสีน้ำตาน้องไม้ใช่ค่ะ
เป็นไม้แบบนี้
ไม้บางทีไม้ไม่เรียกมันมีแบบนี้
อ๋อ
มันมีแหลมถ้าเราจับมันจะทิ่มเทียมแหลมนี่
เขาเรียกว่าอะไรคะเรียกว่าสเสี้ยนเสี้ยน
เสี้ยนน้อเรียนหมายอ้ามันไม่เรียบไม้มัน
ยาวเป็นอะไรจับมันก็ต่ำเจ็บอ่ะ
อาอ้าต่ำงั้นเนี่ยก็จะมีกบเนอะใช้กบตัว
เนี้ยนักเรียนค่ะกบ
กบใสแล้วก็ใสอ่าเสร็จแล้ว
เปลี่ยนน่ะ
เรียนก็จะ
ไม่มีไม่มีเสี้ยนถ้าให้ดีมากค่ะ
มีมะดีเนาะค่ะราคาก็ที่เหลี่ยมจะถามบ้าน
ก็มีอีกมีช่างหมายเนาะอ่ามีใช่ช่างไม้ก็
เลื่อยไม้อาจช่างมายก็ตอกตะปู
ช่างไม้ก็ใช้กบแล้วก็ใส่หน้านี้ให้เรียบ
นะคะแล้วก็มีช่างอะไรคะคุณเรียมมีช่างทา
สี
ทาสีดีนะๆแล้วบ้านครูเรียมสีอะไรคะอ่ะกู
เองไม่สีให้เลือก
แก
ชมพู
สีเขียว
ลล์บ้านเด็กสีขาว
โคนเอี๊ยมสีขาว oku เรียนเวลาฝนตกมันจะ
เปลี่ยนเป็นสีสีดำนี้รู้สึก
สีน้ำตาลไม่มีเหลือนะโอเคหาอ้อมมันจะฆ่า
ข้าฝนตกมากๆมันจะเป็นสีนี้นะคะคุณเรียม
หรือบางทีก็
ชาวบ้านสีขาว
กูเอกก็เมื่อก่อนชอบสีขาว
ว่าก่อนคู๋ก็บ้าคำบ้านสบานอ่าอ่ะมีครูเอง
มี
คุณแม่นะคะ
งี่นาจะเปลี่ยนรถนี้ก่อนนะคะ
มีคุณแม่
และคุณแม่
คุณพ่อ
ข้าน้อยตายอันนี้ครูเอ๋กูเอกก็คิดคิดๆ
ทำบ้าน
บ้านเล็กๆ
หลังเล็กๆๆ
ให้คุณแม่บ้านไอ้เนี่ยให้คุณแม่
คุณแม่คุณแม่เนี่ยคุณแม่
พูดบ้าน
อุ้ย
ขอโทษ
บ้าน
แม่บอกบ้านสีน้ำตาล
คุณแม่บอกบ้านสีน้ำตาล
อยากจะบอกไม่เอาไม่เอาเอาบ้าน
สีขาวอ๋อ
สีน้ำตาลปีข้าวสีน้ำตาลสีขาวสีน้ำตาลปี
ขับกู a  Champion ก็คู๋จ่ายเงินโอเค
Champion โอเค
บ้านสีขาวแต่ตอนนี้บ้าน
กี่ปีแล้วคะ 8 ปี
ปี 9 ปี 9 ปีไม่ 8  9 ปี 9 ปีบ้านเป็น
เอ่อ
สีน้ำตาล
คุณแม่คุณแม่ชอบ
ไก่มาแล้ว
มีญี่ปุ่นไก่ได้เนื้อเพลงไก่
มีเมฆใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็มีฝนตก
สวัสดีไก่
ไก่ขัน
ที่บ้านครูเรียมมีไก่นะฮะใกล้ไก่ไก่
จะได้บอกว่าหมดเวลา
ขอบคุณค่ะกไก่
กลับบ้านคุณแม่นะเวลาฝนตกที่นี่มีดิน
ดินพิมพ์มันขึ้นไปบ้านหรือเปลี่ยนสีน้ำ
ตาลนะคะ
แต่คู่เรียมคะคือเราต้องไปแล้วสำหรับคลิป
นี้นักเรียนคะเราต้องบอกเวลาแล้วใช่ไหมคะ
ไก่บอกว่าหมดเวลาเวลาคู๋ทำคลิปกับครู
เรียมไก่จะเป็นคนเช็คเวลา
ไก่บ้านครูเรียมเข้าใจขึ้นชั่วโมงพอแล้ว
[เพลง]
ใจพูดมากๆแล้วผู้เรียนนั้นคลิปนี้คุณ
เรียนกับครูเอ๋ต้องไปก่อนนะคะนักเรียนไทย
ค่ะเดี๋ยวไว้เจอพี่เก๋กับปู่เรียมในคลิป
หน้านะคะได้ค่ะเจอกันคลิปหน้าค่ะขอบคุณ
มากค่ะคุณเรียมขอบคุณนะคะพูดว่านะคะพี่
เอกขอบคุณค่ะสวัสดีค่ะดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียนสวัสดีค่ะ